-Well, guys, everyone is pumped about this.
Taylor Swift just revealed the full track list
for her upcoming album.
So -- Yeah. [ Cheers and applause ]
I'm excited about just the song names.
So, with that in mind, it is time to play
"Guess the Taylor Swift Song."
Here we go.
-♪ Guess the Taylor Swift song ♪
♪ Guess the song ♪
-Now, here's how this works.
I'm going to give someone in our audience
three different song titles.
One is a real Taylor Swift song. The other two are made up.
You have to guess which one is real.
If you get it right, you get a prize.
If you get it wrong --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you get it wrong, you still get a prize.
Okay. Raise your hand if you want to play this game here.
Right there in the front. Right there.
Yeah. No. Right there. Black shirt. Yeah.
-Me? -Second row, yes.
-Oh. Okay. Cool. -Perfect, yeah.
Hello. What is your name? -Katelyn.
-Hi, Katelyn. Where are you from?
-Originally Wisconsin. Live here now for work.
-Fantastic. Wisconsin. I'll say that.
-It's a great time.
-Now you're a New Yorker. -Yeah.
-Alright, now, which one of these
is the real Taylor Swift song?
Ready? Is it, "A," "Periwinkle Fog"?
Is it, "B," "Lavender Haze"?
Or, "C," "Thundering Produce Section Mist."
-C. Oh, wait. You said real.
So that's -- I'm going to go with B.
[ Laughter ]
-Correct! You got it right. There you go. Congratulations.
She gets a "Periwinkle Fog" sweatshirt.
That is for you. You get it. Congratulations.
Let's get another person.
Raise your hand if you want to play.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I pick that man right there. That gentleman right there.
Yes, very nice. Yes, perfect. Stand up.
Welcome to the show. Thank you for being here.
What is your name? -Jason.
-Jason, where are you from? -Oklahoma.
-Oklahoma. Welcome, buddy.
Jason, which one of these is the Taylor Swift song?
Is it, "A," "Morning Dusk"?
Is it, "B," "Afternoon Drips"?
Or is it, "C," "Midnight Rain"?
-Ooh... Don't -- No help, no help.
No. It's all you.
-C. -You think it's "Midnight Rain."
How would that go if Taylor would sing "Midnight Rain"?
-♪ Midnight rain ♪
♪♪
That's all I got.
-♪ Midnight rain ♪
♪ Midnight rain ♪
♪ On, on, on my brain ♪
That is correct! You won.
And you just won an "Afternoon Drips" sweatshirt right there.
Congratulations, buddy. Let's do one more.
Put your hand up.
Right there behind you with the white hat.
The white hat right there, next to --
I love that "Fallon" sweatshirt, by the way.
-What's going on?! Yeah! -How you doing, buddy?
Nice to see you. -That's right!
-That's right. What is your name?
-I'm...the magician.
No. Lee Martinez.
-You got me. You got me.
I don't understand, but you got me.
-I'm from India. -Yeah, I love it.
Are you a Taylor Swift fan? -Uh, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Why not?
-[ Laughs ] Okay. Are you ready to play this?
Which one of these is a real Taylor Swift song?
Is it, "A," "Question...?"
Is it, "B," "Answer...?"
Or is it, "C," "Um...So That Just Happened..."?
-"That Just Happened." -Oh.
And how would that go?
How would Taylor sing it, do you think, if Taylor sang it?
-♪ Yo, that just happened, where you at? ♪
♪ Give me some beat, hit it, yo! ♪
♪ Yo, yo, I'm Taylor Swift to the beat ♪
♪ Got the beat and... ♪
♪ That just happened yesterday ♪
♪ Don't remember here today ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
Whoo!
-That's how you do it! Yo! That's how you do it, buddy!
-That's right! -Yes! You are correct!
Take it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly what we were all thinking.
Let me see it. Hey, yo, let me see the shirt!
Let me see the shirt. Let me see it. Yeah.
That's what we're all --
That's what we're all thinking right now.
Yeah. There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Taylor Swift, give me the beat ♪
♪ Taylor Swift ♪ Fantastic!
Thank you so much for playing that. That was fun.